economía directo américa de france 24
nuevamente àngel hablando está con
nosotros para hablar de que más bancos
se suman al aumento de las tasas de
interés el como arma para como arma para
contrarrestar inflación para
contrarrestar la inflación raúl de la
reserva federal de eeuu decidió un
aumento de 75 puntos básicos en su tasa
de intervención este es un movimiento
que no hacía desde hace casi tres
décadas en esta manera se sitúa entre el
1,5 y el 1 75 por ciento esa tasa de
interés pero la fed no está sola en esta
batalla el banco central de brasil
también subió sus tasas al 1325 este es
su mayor nivel en seis años hoy lo
hicieron los emisores de hong kong y de
taiwán en europa suiza sorprendió con la
misma medida y el banco de inglaterra
elevó sus tipos al nivel más alto desde
2019 y como están entonces operando las
bolsas al día de hoy la mayoría de raúl
opera a la baja después de la decisión
agresiva pero poco sorprendente del
banco central de eeuu las fuertes caídas
entonces en europa
solamente están relacionados con estos
sino también con la expectativa de lo
que vaya a ser el banco central europeo
que se reúne y hablando de empresas una
icónica marca de maquillaje se declaró
en quiebra una noticia que de interés
general interesa a usted me interesa a
mí le interesa a mariluz nuestra si
nuestra maquilladora pues mire estamos
hablando de la estadounidense revlon de
90 años que se acogió al capítulo 11 de
la ley de quiebras de eeuu agobiada por
una gran deuda y por los altos costos
derivados de los problemas en las
cadenas de suministro ahora miremos
tiene deudas de largo plazo de más de
3.300 millones de dólares está
fabricante de marcas que van desde
productos como al mail hasta elisabeth
arden ahora busca financiamiento por
cerca de 600 millones de dólares y es
que en 2021 tuvo una caída del 22 por
ciento en sus ventas frente a lo que
mostraba en 2017 esta empresa raúl o
todos lo sabemos ha sido un pilar en los
estantes de las tiendas de eeuu durante
décadas y de todo el mundo pero en los
últimos años luchó no solamente con una
grande sino con una competencia más dura
y la incapacidad de seguir el ritmo de
los cambiantes gustos de belleza ahora
hay que aclarar la bancarrota no
significa necesariamente que la marca
desaparece sino que reorganiza sus
deudas precisamente para no desaparecer
dar y daba seguridad datos de la bolsa y
nuestro productor nos acaba de decir
pues que el nasdaq también y el down
jones abrieron muy a la baja en esta
apertura de las bolsas que se acaba de
dar en eeuu son un dato pues para que no
se quedara como pues quedarse así es
vamos ahora a hablar de rusia porque
reconoce que su economía no volverá a
ser la misma no volverá a ser la misma
lo dicen las autoridades económicas del
kremlin que son protagonistas en el foro
económico internacional de san
petersburgo la versión rusa del foro
económico mundial de davos y que este
año tiene apenas una cuarta parte de sus
visitantes uno de los pocos asistentes
es el ministro de energía de arabia
saudita y esto es clave porque es el
principal productor de petróleo de la
opep y rusia es su aliado la gobernadora
del banco central admitió que las
sanciones de occidente van a tener un
fuerte impacto sobre las finanzas
escuchemos
está claro para todos que las cosas no
serán como solían ser y seguimos
repitiendo esa frase bastante banal no
hay vuelta atrás el mundo ha cambiado
pero qué es exactamente lo que no será
igual está claro que la situación es
bueno difícil ahora es importante no
repartir puntos sino ser más flexibles y
cambiamos información dani porque
ingeniero discuten sobre patentes de
vacunas hoy debería haber concluido la
décimo segunda conferencia ministerial
de la organización mundial del comercio
y la primera en cuatro años sin embargo
decidieron extenderla porque no han
llegado a acuerdos la dificultad ha sido
que los 164 miembros deben estar de
acuerdo para que se aprueben reglas
comerciales globales o sea que por uno
sólo pueden bloquearlo y ese miembro en
esta oportunidad de sindh ya que por
años ha mantenido subsidios a la pesca y
a la agricultura esta organización lo
que está buscando es precisamente acabar
con esos subsidios que causan sobrepesca
firmar compromisos de seguridad
alimentaria en situaciones de crisis y
el punto más álgido ahora mismo liberar
las patentes de las vacunas contra el
cubit 19 escuchemos
sin hemos visto en los últimos 20 meses
que gobiernos como reino unido suiza y
la unión europea han bloqueado la
propuesta de suspensión de patentes y en
lugar de ello tenemos una alternativa
muy poco adecuada que luego más allá de
las vacunas no libera de forma apropiada
las barreras legales necesarias para
producir vacunas y no cubre tests y
tratamientos que se necesitan ahora
porque está muriendo genere vamos a ver
entonces cómo fue la apertura de wall
street en la mañana de hoy raúl
recordemos que las tasas de interés son
el coco el enemigo número uno el logro
de la sacar más a distant todo el rojo
todo a la bola en reunir el 2,24 por
ciento 2,67 por cierto en el standard
and poor's estas son las cifras que se
veían durante la pandemia en los peores
momentos 3% 4% al día y como lo dijo se
ve venir pues con todo lo que está
pasando en todo el contexto
internacional danny muchísimas gracias
entonces como siempre por toda la
información económica mañana viernes más
economía por supuesto vamos directo
hasta parís